Speaker 1: I got a number of
emails from folks over the weekend
saying, David, we don't have to worry about
the Senate anymore. We don't have to worry
about the Senate because Adam Laxalt
was defeated by Cortez Masto in Nevada
and Democrats now have guaranteed a majority,
5050 in the Senate. And that is true. But 51
versus 50 is of massive importance. 51 means that
Joe Manchin or Kirsten Cinema. Right. But Joe
Manchin has been the bigger problem is no longer
necessary on votes that require a simple majority.
And it means you only need nine Republicans
instead of ten when you need 60 votes in the
Senate. This cannot be understated. So
let's talk through it. When it comes to
federal judges as an example, it is of critical
importance that Democrats control the Senate
and Democrats do. And those are simple majorities.
And generally speaking, neither Joe Manchin nor
Kirsten cinema have been obstacles when it comes
to those sorts of votes. But there are all sorts
of other bills and proposals where Manchin
has been a problem. And Manchin has done the
rounds on the Sunday shows and has made himself
into this decider, for lack of a better term,
because Democrats were able to coalesce 49 votes,
but not 50 specifically because of Joe Manchin.
If, indeed, Raphael Warnock defeats Herschel
Walker in the December 6th runoff, one Senator,
you could take your pick. MANCHIN Or cinema no
longer matters when you simply need 50 plus Kamala
Harris's tie breaking vote. There is another
really important reason why this runoff is still
important, even though Democrats now control the
Senate either way, and that is that 2024 is a much
more difficult Senate map and Georgia would be one
seat that does not have to be won in 2024 in order
to maintain a majority. Consider that we've been
talking about the 2024 Senate election for years.
33 Senate seats are up in 2024, and it is not a
good map for Democrats. Democrats have to defend
seats in Montana, Ohio and West Virginia. Jon
Tester in Montana, a Democrat. Montana is very,
very red. He won with 50.3% last time. Really,
really slim margin. Sherrod Brown in Ohio,
a Democrat, won with 53% in 2018. A little more
margin there, but still not an easy race. And then
in West Virginia, Joe Manchin won with under
50%. Think about that with under 50% and with
Joe Manchin and West Virginia being such a red
state, we don't even know whether Joe Manchin is
running yet. I don't have the latest, but I
believe the latest information is Manchin is
not yet committed to running in 2024. If Manchin
doesn't run and it comes down to a further left
Democrat versus a Republican in West Virginia,
it very well may be that that is a seat that
Democrat. My earpiece is flopping all over. That
even may be a seat that Democrats potentially
give up. So the Senate map is so tough in 2024
that controlling the Senate in 24 may depend
on whether Raphael Warnock or Herschel Walker win
on December six. So I think I'm making the stakes
pretty clear here. Last thing on this. Imagine
if for the last two years, Democrats had had 51
rather than 50 votes and the number of bills
on which the entire circus sideshow with Joe
Manchin could have been skipped altogether. So
this is still an absolutely critical runoff for
different reasons than it was critical 48 or 72
hours ago. We're going to be doing livestreams,
getting involved in that race. Many of you
were saying I actually should go to Georgia.
I just don't know that I can do it in the next
couple of weeks with everything I have going on.
But we are going to do as much as we can on that
race and more information about that upcoming.